We're here with Nadya Direkova,
a staff designer at Google and a design
print master will run more design print
more than anyone else in the company.
Thank you for joining us.
>> Thank you for having me.
>> So, when should an entrepreneur
think of design and
user experience when
building their product?
>> That's a great question.
The answer is right away, I don't
believe that there is a successful
product that separate
from being a product or
something that's carefully designed.
So as soon as someone's thinking
about starting a company,
it's useful to think about what is it
they want to bring to the world, and
that starts the design process.
>> Right, and
when you don't have a designer or
you can't afford
a designer what do you do?
>> So we'd like to believe that anyone
can have some of the skills that
a designer has.
Note the skills in Photoshop
actually rendering beautiful mocks.
But the kinds of questions
that the designer asks,
we're hoping to cover some of
these today so that you can learn,
what are the design skills that can
help you quickly tackle your product and
the chief results with your team,
even if you're not a designer.
>> You'll hear more about design
spreads from Nadia in the next lesson.